one of the main reasons why we age is
stem cell exhaustion so what that means
is when your child you have about 200
million stem cells per person and then
by the time you're eight years old you
only have like one million stem cells
per cell so you're going from like 200
down to like one when your body stores
the stem cells get depleted your ability
to regenerate and repair tissue DNA
damage fight off infection phytos Cancer
all that stuff just decreases because
one of the reasons is you don't have
this many stem cells so now we can do
what are called intravenous stem cells
so they go IV and they go through your
whole body and they help to replenish
your stem cell stores